étranger
savez-vous ce que je déteste chez les
américains
tout
est
ça va être bruyant comment saviez-vous que j'étais
un flic tu ne ressembles pas à un avocat
papa
c'est ce que tu as fait
double 07. de plainfield new jersey
détends-toi tu es en sécurité maintenant
sauve mon cul
la mauvaise nouvelle de ce mec
armes terroristes uranium de qualité
nucléaire
quelqu'un doit l'arrêter whoa
qu'est-ce que c'est un pistolet de pirate c'est de la vieille
école
comme toi
je suppose que tu l'as déjà fait avant de ne pas
m'encourager
moi et mon  garçon ici
je vais te mettre une arme
vraiment
ouvert
tu cherches des ennuis il ne
te trouve pas toujours posons nous encore
la même question
toi